you know my
um sorry uh uh sorry about this
he's not a natural showman he does get
nervous
my mum tried to get us over our shyness
to challenge ourselves we allowed them
to do a lot of dangerous things that
slid on to a few more Dairy things
drives on Jeopardy
attenuation of his childhood having
suffered from dyslexia having left
school at 15 I had a lot to prove
he has a bundle of contradictions people
were seduced into thinking that this was
a bumbling good guy when in fact Richard
always had a very firm eye on the bottom
line
we had to use every trick in the book I
don't believe that virgin could be what
it is today if he hadn't have done the
Boat Crossings and the balloon Crossings
we're going to space
risk-taking is a drug
drug that started as a child and
discontinued in my life ever since
Richard was capable of spending every
single penny on some project that was
going to lose it all
we've never taken it for granted that
this couldn't all just disappear
the spaceships had a catastrophic
failure
it's just Garcia or Ram
if you've learned the art of trying the
impossible you could turn that to trying
to do the impossible with anything
that is a gifty has
there is a danger that by having that
attitude that it could go horribly wrong
I just feel that you should throw
yourself into life
life is short anyway
and I think it should be lived to its
full
[Applause]
foreign